in the wake of the Facebook Donald Trump
2016 campaign data scandal the
opposition research and data mining firm
Cambridge analytic ah is shutting the
whole thing down and the uk-based
company has filed for insolvency they
are starting bankruptcy proceedings and
they claim were no longer profitable all
of the bad media coverage has driven
away all of our customers and suppliers
and we all need to be very very vigilant
about the possibility that they are just
going to reopen under another name which
they are already doing and much like
with yesterday's Rudy Guiliani spilling
the beans about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars being reimbursed to
Michael Cohen by Donald Trump corporate
media by and large is falling for this
let me tell you a little story
remember the mercenary firm Blackwater
owned by Betsy DeVos as brother Eric
Prince doesn't exist anymore right well
a little sort of they changed their name
to Z Services XE Services in 2009 then
in 2011 they again changed their names
to a company called Academy with an eye
on the end instead of a Y and they're
basically still doing the exact same
thing now maybe that won't happen here
but the parent company of Cambridge
analytic ah is also closing down called
SCL Group so if the plan was for SCL
group to just start a different
subsidiary doesn't appear that that's
going to happen but what we did learn is
that it just so happens that a new
company has been set up called Emer data
that company was registered in August of
2017 but just six weeks ago the major
players at Cambridge analytic I have all
of a sudden joined as directors of this
new company Emer data and the daughters
of Robert Mercer the Trump supporting
billionaire are directors of Emer data
now Alexandre Nick's the former CEO of
Cambridge analytic ah who was caught on
camera in that really good channel for
investigation he's a director of Emer
data julian Wheatland who is the
chairman was the chairman of Cambridge
analytic ah he has also joined Emer data
as a director Alexander
hailer the chief data officer of
Cambridge analytic ah is also now a
director at Emer data amazing now what
will they do what will they not do it's
not really clear the company Emer data
which again was registered back in
August of 2017 is registered as formally
being in the data processing hosting and
related activities industry could that
be opposition research and the same type
of data mining that Cambridge analytical
was doing absolutely and by the way I
mentioned black water earlier black
water isn't just an analogy to what
happened here but it's actually
connected to this Emer data story
Johnson changshan Co is the deputy
chairman of Frontier Services Group he
is a director at Emer data and he's
directly connected to this entire thing
through the company formerly known as
black water in that frontier is
currently chaired by none other than
Eric Prince
Betsy DeVos is brother and the former
founder or founder and former director
of black water do these companies ever
really die right because there's always
a market for these technically mostly
legal but sometimes over the line
services in the world sort of influence
underbelly and that's really what links
together the data research firms and the
data mining and the opposition research
and the lobbyists and all the chrony
elements of the structure that we have
based on our campaign finance system
it's that there's this underbelly of
demand for what they do and it is really
really difficult when you have demand
for a product or service to completely
eliminate it right you can make it
illegal you can push it into a black
market but as we know has making drugs
illegal in many countries reduce the
demand for those drugs no and because
there's still a demand for those drugs
you still have people who are going to
for the right price provide a service or
make the product available and that's
the exact same thing here right just
because the reputation of Cambridge
analytical has been tarnished such that
at least publicly
people are saying listen we can't work
with Cambridge analytic after what you
were involved in
well what about working with Mr data a
company that was registered in August of
2017 that's not a problem whatsoever
because who even knows who these
companies are until they actually have a
scandal in their history so the same
people clearly going to be operating an
almost identical business under a
different name probably even the same
client list because you know what if
Cambridge analytical was delivering for
you you're not going to say oh because
you got caught doing the Trump stuff we
can't work with you they're gonna say we
can't be publicly associated with a
company called Cambridge analytical but
yeah just restructure as Emer data and
of course we'll rehire you and get back
together and maybe it even provides an
opportunity for Cambridge analytical to
get some of the dead wood some of the
people that were hanging on to
employment that maybe really shouldn't
have send me your thoughts about this is
corporate media falling for this entire
thing or am I missing something here is
this really the end of Cambridge
analytic because services as we know
them I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show today's program is made possible in
part by fruit or which is a social
forecasting game for your phone where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
go on the app find a future event you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
that you think will happen using the
apps in-game fake currency if your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points you can compete with others
who are making their own prediction to
see who is the best forecaster there's
no real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of futur is interacting
with others and showing the world your
skills at predicting the future will
Democrats take the White House this year
will Trump run for re-election will
Trump ever build the wall you can go
ahead and make your predictions show off
your forecasting skills and there are
also monthly competitions and prizes for
top forecasters and I'm on foote or you
can wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and
make forecast it's free it's on Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers and
it's spelled fut you you are calm